trading it's it's real right it's you
and me and you know a million other guys
mostly men we're looking at the markets
and we're saying you know what's going
to happen and you know nowadays I work
in in media and I've got a YouTube
channel and stuff and I make a lot of
predictions in the media and um I made a
prediction at the beginning of covid
that after lockdown we'd have a massive
inflationary cost of living crisis you
know you can read that's an article in
the guardian in June 2020 you know three
years later nobody remembers
when you're on the trading floor you
make those predictions everybody
remembers because everybody sees your
number right so you know as you know
because you've read the book I have very
ambivalent mixed feelings about about
trading and about games in fact but
trading for me is the biggest game and
it's the closest we've got to a fair One
D even if it's not entirely Fair